[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
fail now
[Music]
all right folks
I'm in the truck now
and it is extremely hot out here uh
I had to stack all that or uh put all
that hay and Rose
our hay trailer will haul eight Bales at
a time so I put it in eight Bell rows
all throughout the property
so that I can just bring the truck and
trailer out here and have the tractor
sitting there and just load eight and
move on load eight and move on
so anyway this was a lot easier way of
getting a count on actually how much hay
there actually was and
um
so
I'm just going to go around here and
show you what we got okay
in the in that little field that you saw
at the end of the hay cutting video that
they were cutting a little square field
there are
I have put eight Bales in here but
they're it actually made Seven I brought
one from outside
to make an eight Bale row right there
so there's eight
all right let me go on across here
in this little field right here it made
a lot because there was no second
cutting on it last year
so it was the old stuff and the new
stuff all together
and uh it actually made more hay it's
two acres and it made Seven bales
so
you go into the next field which is the
big how you feel
one of the big hay fields
and right here
we made a tiny one and then a about a
half a bale and then there's a
see how many we got there one two three
four five six seven and then a half a
bell and then a tiny bell so we're going
to consider that half a bell and a tiny
bell one Bell so eight Bells right there
all right so it's 16.
then we move across here
and these hay fields are rough I know
they look smooth there's glass from the
air but
hayfields are always rough
so
so we had 16 here's another eight Bale
row
three four five six seven eight
so that makes 24. so we got 24 bales
so far
all right
24 then we'll go across here
and here is another row
of hey eight Bales there
so that makes
two
all right
so we got 32 Bales which is pretty sad
for the amount of area that we we
actually bailed we bailed it
pretty huge area you saw from the air I
mean I think I think all of the hay
baling area
is about 60 Acres of open ground
so
you know
we're not doing good so far on the
amount of hate so we got 32 Bales so far
now I'm going to take a shortcut
up through here
almost cut
field
on the neighbor area
all right
cut around behind here
pretty narrow little spot right here
all right remember we had 32 bales
all right 32 bales
right
there's eight over there that's 40.
so there's
it makes 40
. there are eight Bales straight ahead
of me
so that makes
48 with this eight here and then we go
get right over here
and we have another eight
right there
so all in all we have
bales
56 bales
we fed about
75 Bales last year
so
and my brother needs at least 30.
so we're gonna have to at least make
100 510 bales
uh in order to kind of break even this
year so the good news is it well bad
news bad news it's a hundred today
the good news is it's supposed to start
cooling off today and there are chances
of rain coming
several chances of rain over the next
two weeks they're not great chances but
they are chances
so if we get some rain
there's a possibility we can get that
second cutting that we need but right
now we are in a deficit on Hay
[Applause]
foreign
folks that is when the microphone
decided to die so what we have here is
we have a 32 10 10
uh
ratio of fertilizer it is nitrogen
phosphorus and potassium
32 nitrogen so it's a nitrogen Rich what
they do is they take a skid steer and
they load this Hopper with the amount
that we wanted
it goes from the Hopper into a tumbler
and what that does is just like Mixing
concrete it goes into that um
into that shot in there by the conveyor
and it is mixed up well inside of that
uh
inside of that uh little tumbler there
so then after it is mixed well in the
tumbler it goes on to that conveyor belt
it's right there below it and that
conveyor belt it runs up and it loads
itself right into the uh trailer that
I'm pulling the fertilizer trailer
so this is purchased four tons of this
and uh the uh and I and I hate it
because he he wanted to know what I was
doing what I was feeling I believe his
name is either I think it's Jason or
Jaden
um he was helping me out with uh
with putting the fertilizer in there
and he was doing a he was doing a
bang-up job and uh
I really appreciate his help getting me
lined up getting the the trailer lined
up and uh that's where I can get on it
real good and uh and smoothing out the
fertilizer so it wasn't
you know flying out whenever I was going
down the road
so yep I appreciated their help down at
the co-op so anyway
uh the fertilizer cost was
a little bit north of twenty five
hundred dollars so
[Music]
okay this is more area where the audio
was broken so what I'm showing is how to
work the fertilizer trailer so what you
do is you pull this pin right here that
holds a lever once you get the pin out
you're able to move the lever to the
side
and what you're trying to do is you
slide it up past this plate right here
and then you lock it in once you do that
that rod runs this little wheel with
fins on it which pushes down into that
tire which engages that and then you'll
see right here there's some belts that
run the actual conveyor system and the
uh and the actual Spinners that that
throw the fertilizer this is a gauge
that shows uh actually a chart that
shows if you want to flow a certain
amount of fertilizer then you have a
gate opening rate that you use so we're
going to do a 200 pounds per acre and
it's going to be like a two and a half
inch uh gate opening and and I run the
truck at about oh five to seven miles an
hour to get the required 200 pounds of
fertilizer so what I'm doing right here
is I'm actually opening that gate up to
the two and a half
inch Mark to allow the fertilizer to
flow and that you can see the fertilizer
is sitting actually on a conveyor and it
brings it back and runs it onto these uh
actual spinner wheels that are that that
I failed to get
video of right then that are below that
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
folks I've got all the fertilizer
sprayed I got to spread all over the
property here where the cattle are where
uh
where the hay is
you can see
the nitrogen on the ground here
so what we're attempting to do now is
wait wait out the rain
when the rain comes
then this will just uh just take off
but in the meantime
I saw something whenever I was driving
around here and I need to find it if I
can
um
I didn't I didn't think it was going to
be this quick but
I believe we've got a new baby calf
so let me find that if I can
I'm looking oh there she is
right here
baby
this is 23 Cal
she is Minnie's mama
and that is Danny's first baby and look
at them ears
and this baby appears to have just been
born
but it's up
and it's moving around well and she
looks like she's got a bag
oh don't fall down
I wonder if this was a little
bull or a heifer
oh look at those ears you sure tell
Danny's your daddy
uh we got some little heifer
a little heifer
so
that's a keeper
all right
I'm just gonna kind of leave them alone
for a minute
I need some help with this
I need to get a I need to get an ear tag
in that calf but
let me see if I can maybe my brother's
home and he can come give me a hand I
don't know we will see I'm gonna leave
them alone for a minute
anyway
we got a
new baby on killing Farms
all right the next couch getting ready
to have calf is right here this is uh
this is Oreo and she has got her bag
going real well
and she should be having a calf just any
day so
Oreo is next in line
followed by
two or three of the other cattle so uh
yep Oreo is coming she'll be next so
that'll be the next calf
that update should be just any day
all right what a day
what a day we got the fertilizing all
done on both properties on the uh on the
hay field and out here at uh where the
cattle are
uh we have a we had a complete surprise
when we got here whenever I uh found
that uh number 20 or number 23 cow had
had a nice little heifer calf out of
Danny this is our first calf from Danny
and you know you always wonder if that
bull that you bought is going to be a
good bull you know we bought that bull
we didn't test him ourselves but what
the fellow told us he tested him he come
out good and he showed me pictures of
all of his calves and he had a lot of
nice calves and you can definitely tell
this is Danny's baby I mean he's got 30
those ears so uh but anyway we
so now we've got the a new calf we got
everything all fertilized up
I guess the next thing I got to do is I
got to come out here and do some brush
hogging I need to ear tag this calf it's
a little bit uh
I've got to get that that buggy back to
the co-op because I've got it rented and
I I've got to get it back before they
close so I'm going to run it back and
I need to brush hog here
I noticed that uh the Briar is down on
the on their side of the pond are really
taking over so I need to come down and
brush hog and I need to see if I can get
an ear tag in that calf so that'll
probably be the next time so anyway
everybody's happy happy happy
and we got a new baby so if you like
this type of content like And subscribe
and we'll continue to bring more content
in the future and as always everybody
God bless
together